as great as Grand Theft Auto 5 is it's
hard to deny that it's showing its age
fortunately if you waited to pick up the
game on PC you can reverse time well
sort of a new Grand Theft Auto 5 PC mod
offering a comprehensive set of tweaks
and changes has been released the mod
created by Josh romito is titled the
pinnacle of 5 and it delivers
considerably more than just a
nip-and-tuck for graphics the
description reads not only is this a
visual enhancement but literally every
aspect of the game has been tweaked
adjusted and fine-tuned to create most
realistic stunning and immersive Grand
Theft Auto experience the changes
include improvements to visuals and
sound but there are also deeper gameplay
changes such as improve relationship
dynamics weapon destruction vehicle
handling and more the lighting has also
been improved reflections look better
smoke effects are more realistic and the
list goes on the mod also includes a
texture overhaul that encompasses flood
effects foliage clouds water and much
much more the population levels in
certain areas have also been increased
and all the weapons have been tweaked as
well now you just need to make sure your
pieces can run this mod for the full
list of tweaks and changes head over to
gamespot com
you